hi I'm Nicolas we with reason TV and
today we're talking with Thomas Haslett
he's an a professor of economics and law
at George Mason University and we are
talking about the 25th anniversary of
the repeal of the Fairness Doctrine Tom
thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me
what was the Fairness Doctrine and why
was it a good thing that it got repealed
so the Fairness Doctrine was a
regulation promulgated by the Federal
Communications Commission as a condition
of a radio or a TV license and this
comes from 1949 the licensees had a
two-pronged obligation a they had to
cover controversial issues of importance
in their community so they couldn't just
stand by and not do any news or public
affairs reporting secondly they had to
cover those issues from a quote balanced
perspective unquote so that meant they
were supposed to show both sides of an
issue that they couldn't just be totally
pimping for one side or one party well I
mean that's the idea behind now that's
the idea Plus that they they can't just
be a classical music station in
Connecticut right they have to do
something that has to do with
controversial public issues why is that
a bad thing that sounds great
we're all about fairness right so this
America it does sound great yeah if we
were gonna stop at the the label we'd
stop right there the fact is however
that there is a frontal conflict between
the First Amendment to the US
Constitution freedom of speech freedom
of the press and the government
considering whether or not the fairness
of a particular report passes muster so
in print media newspapers for example
it's quite clear that there is no
Fairness Doctrine nor can there be not
only a Fairness Doctrine but a right of
reply equal time rule and any any
journalist and you know any print
journalist would say you know how dare
the government tell me what we're gonna
be writing or a publisher or anything
but that was as I was seen as totally
different if we're talking about ABC NBC
CBS or local TV over-the-air affiliates
why were people willing to carve out
this gigantic exception to the First
Amendment well I mean it's not people
it's a certain subset of the population
certainly
there they're interested in favor of
what's called the quid pro quo now it's
not just the regulator's it's not just
you know interest groups agitating for
more government some people might say
censorship others might call it
regulation or responsible reasonable
regulation but the broadcaster's
themselves were involved in the
so-called quid pro quo it's comes
literally from the 1927 radio act and in
this arrangement of 1927 radioactive
centrally created the modern FCC and the
regulation of giving out licenses that
gave you a minato what is now the FCC
but the the fact is that the government
gets to set certain licenses into the
market and it sets conditions on how
those licenses are used and if some of
the conditions abridge the First
Amendment that's a problem for
broadcasters who might want to have free
speech on the other hand if the
broadcasters are getting benefits out of
that system they might go along with it
having the license was worth a lot more
than having the right of free expression
on that yes and so that developed you
know what were some of the cases where
FCC regulators started turning the
screws on broadcasters or politicians
you know we're using the Fairness
Doctrine as a way to squelch free speech
even though it was supposed to actually
problem yeah well thankfully and quite
uniquely in this area we have a
documentary record of what happened with
activities political activities to
actually silence political opposition
under the Fairness Doctrine has to do
with a very famous Supreme Court case
called red lion vs. FCC now what
happened in red lion well red lion was a
tiny AM station in Pennsylvania that had
put I was owned by an evangelist
conservative quite conservative and he
had Billy James Hargis on the air buying
time for 15 minutes one day and just
after the 1964 election Hargis attacked
a journalist named Fred cook who had
written a book called Goldwater
extremists on the right
well Cooke sent a letter to the station
saying I'm demand free equal time the
owner of the station sent back a note
saying look you can buy 15 minutes for
seven dollars and 50 cents
the same price we sold it to mr. Hargis
for and cook says no I get free time you
attack me it's only fair to get this
right of reply and in fact that's what
the rule is well he went to the FCC
where that the FCC found four cook they
went to the courts and the courts went
all the way through the process and the
Supreme Court sided with the FCC well it
turns out that the say the case was a
setup the Democratic National Committee
had been conducting court you know had
surveillance in essence on all these
radio stations there are a lot of
conservative stations and the Kennedy
Johnson administration was very
concerned about their speech and they
literally went into business with a full
time monitoring operation to file
Fairness Doctrine or equal time right of
reply requests to harass and intimidate
the station's hopefully would be too
expensive for them to continue having
this form of speech and that they would
just do something else go to some other
evangelical kind of programming and in
fact that documentary record has come
out wonderfully in a book by Fred
friendly after he retired from CBS wrote
a book called the good guys the bad guys
in the First Amendment
now this documentary record was not
available to the Supreme Court in 1969
they missed the whole thing they missed
the they said you know if there had been
some chilling of fact we might have
found against the government we don't
see any evidence of that and in fact
there the whole thing was a chilling
effect the whole thing was was you know
Fred cook with with a very large
financial backing from some political
interests trying to intimidate some
speakers who had a viewpoint they didn't
like well you flash forward to the late
1980s Ronald Reagan a former broadcaster
himself a guy who knew media somewhat he
got rid of the Fairness Doctrine why did
he do it
well I think there was some ideological
component to it but there also was a
very hefty evidentiary record that there
had been a chilling effect part of it
I've just mentioned the Fred friendly
book the FCC did a very large report in
1985 that interview people like Dan
Rather who had been involved both as a
print journalist and a broadcast
journalist and they documented the
chilling effect to the extent that the
government documents these kinds of
things so in 1987 the FCC went forward
and repealed the the regulation now they
didn't really want to do it that way
they actually went to the courts
originally and asked the core
to throw the the law out and the courts
laughed at the FCC you know look this is
your pic ulation okay you know if you
want to repeal it you can repeal it now
of course the reason that the even the
Reagan FCC went to the courts they
didn't want the liability on this they
knew Congress the Democratic Congress
was going to be very upset if they took
this measure and of course the the Wrath
of Khan came down on the FCC the
Democrats in Congress were very
displeased by this deregulatory move did
the repeal of the Fairness Doctrine give
rise to talk radio and if so is that a
bad thing
well I think that there's no question
that there is a causality that the
deregulation allowed there to be much
more diversity and controversy and the
the whole idea the Fairness Doctrine was
shown to be a chilling effect you you
you and you undid that chilling effect
and you got a lot more and you did get
air America you know which comes in and
out you get a lot of other stuff we have
a lot of content now just not on audio a
satellite radio and some of the and some
of the diversity you do see in the in
the in radio but you obviously in the in
the cable world you have entire channels
now that are under a D regulatory regime
that specialize in serving ideologically
oriented audiences and that's the sort
of diversity and free speech that we
never had under the Fairness Doctrine
and you hear this on a regular basis
people saying we need to bring the
Fairness Doctrine back we need is is
there any real possibility that after
this 25-year experiment in really in
much more free speech much more robust
speech from every possible angle is it
likely that the Fairness Doctrine will
come back it's not likely I mean it's
you know you can say the cattle are out
of the corral in this case it was always
a flimsy rationale to say that the
government should be able to license and
then to get into content issues from
that licensing function just because of
the distribution platform now the
distribution platforms have converged
and so print media or reason.com how do
you differentiate between one medium
it's exactly the same content so the
principles have become obliterated
beyond all recognition so we really have
moved beyond that to move back would be
very problematic on you know just the
practical ground so I don't think it's
coming I want to thank Tom Hayes lid of
George Mason University for talking to
us about the glorious 25th anniversary
of free speech thanks to the repeal of
the Fair
miss doctor thanks sure
you